go to you just regular white American
no I didn't say you're basic I hate when
women do this [__] what is this thing
where you find the [__] insult in any
regular sentence
what's the problem I didn't talk about
your looks I said you're plain American
I didn't say you look like a plain five
that would be different I've noticed
women are like truffle pigs for insults
I'm not calling you pigs don't do that
either I see you trying to [__] you
know how we find truffles right there's
only one animal that can sniff them out
they're buried deep in the ground and
there's a truffle pig we can't see
anything but 10 feet beneath the soil
truffle pigs are sniffing
that is women with insults I had to
learn how to navigate a sentence you
can't just be like baby you look good
today
what's that supposed to mean I think
you're a girl oh today I'm
every day you're beautiful then how come
you said today I don't know